are you one of the many who dreams of
becoming a data scientist keep watching
this video if you're passionate about
data science because we will tell you
how does it really work under the hood
emma is a data scientist let's see how a
day in her life goes while she's working
on data science project well it is very
important to understand the business
problem first in our meeting with the
clients emma asks relevant questions
understands and defines objectives for
the problem that needs to be tackled she
is a curious soul who asks a lot of eyes
one of the many traits of a good data
scientist
now she gears up for data acquisition to
gather and scrape data from multiple
sources like web servers logs databases
apis and online repositories oh it seems
like finding the right data takes both
time and effort after the data is
gathered comes data preparation this
step involves data cleaning and data
transformation data cleaning is the most
time consuming process as it involves
handling many complex scenarios here
emma deals with inconsistent data types
misspelled attributes missing values
duplicate values and what not then in
data transformation she modifies the
data based on defined mapping rules in a
project etl tools like talent and
informatica are used to perform complex
transformations that helps the team to
understand the data structure better
then understanding what you actually can
do with your data is very crucial for
that emma does exploratory data analysis
with the help of eda she defines and
refines the selection of feature
variables that will be used in the model
development but what if emma skips this
step she might end up choosing the wrong
variables which will produce an
inaccurate model thus exploratory data
analysis becomes the most important step
now she proceeds to the core activity of
a data science project which is data
modeling she repetitively applies
diverse machine learning techniques like
k n decision tree knife base to the data
to identify the model that best fits the
business requirement she trains the
models on the training data set and test
them to select the best performing model
emma prefers python for modeling the
data however it can also be done using r
and sas well the trickiest part is not
yet over visualization and communication
emma meets the clients again to
communicate the business findings in a
simple and effective manner to convince
the stakeholders she uses tools like
tableau power bi and click view that can
help her in creating powerful reports
and dashboards and then finally she
deploys and maintains the model she
tests the selected model in a
pre-production environment before
deploying it in the production
environment which is the best practice
right after successfully deploying it
she uses reports and dashboards to get
real-time analytics further she also
monitors and maintains the project's
performance well that's how emma
completes the data science project we
have seen the daily routine of a data
scientist is a whole lot of fun has a
lot of interesting aspects and comes
with its own share of challenges now
let's see how data science is changing
the world data science techniques along
with genomic data provides a deeper
understanding of genetic issues in
reaction to particular drugs and
diseases logistic companies like dhl
fedex have discovered the best rules to
ship the best suited time to deliver the
best mode of transport to choose thus
leading to cost efficiency with data
science it is possible to not only
predict employee attrition but to also
understand the key variables that
influence employee turnover also the
airline companies can now easily predict
flight delay and notify the passengers
beforehand to enhance their travel
experience well if you're wondering
there are various roles offered to a
data scientist like data analyst machine
learning engineer deep learning engineer
data engineer and of course data
scientist the median base salaries of a
data scientist can range from 95 000 to
165 000
so that was about the data science are
you ready to be a data scientist if yes
then start today the world of data needs
you
hello and welcome to the session on data
science with python so what are we going
to do in this session we will talk about
what is data science and some of the
basics of python as you may be aware
data science we use either python or r
as some of the tools and programming
languages so this session the focus is
on python so we will talk about the
basics of python why to learn python how
to install python and then we will talk
about some of the important libraries
which are required for
data analysis and then we will go into a
little bit of details about exploratory
data analysis and we will take an
example there of
loan prediction and we will see a little
bit about data wrangling using pandas
which is one of the libraries of python
and then we will end up with small
predictive model or logistic regression
model which is a part of machine
learning and in case you need more
details about machine learning in this
session we will probably not go into the
details of machine learning there is a
separate session you might want to look
at there is a separate video on machine
learning you might want to take a look
at that if you need more details here we
are just giving a quick overview to see
how we can use the scikit-learn library
so we will not go into a lot of details
about the basics of machine learning all
right so with that let's move forward so
what is data science data science is
about finding insights from the data so
if there is a lot of data if you have
sufficient data how to analyze and find
some insights out of it this is what is
data science all about a couple of
examples here customer prediction now
let's say you have a customer base and
you want to find out who are most likely
to buy your product so you can use from
your past behavior you can probably
develop a model and try to predict who
are the people out of the thousand leads
or
potential customers who will actually
buy so there may be some patterns that
you can use to predict similarly service
planning so for example you're running a
restaurant and you want to know how many
people will be coming or how many
customers will be visiting your
restaurant on a given day now based on
your historical data you can build a
model to predict that as well so that
there is no wastage of food and so on
and so forth so these are
very quick and easy examples of how data
science can be used in business now
let's uh talk about python for doing
data science we need some kind of a
programming language or a tool and so on
so this session will be about python
there are other tools like for example r
and we will probably do a separate video
on that but this session is on python
and you must have already heard python
is really becoming very popular
everybody is talking about python not
only data science in iot and ai and many
other places so it's a very popular it's
getting very popular so if you are not
yet familiar with python this may be a
good time to get started with it so why
do we want to use python so basically
python is used as a programming language
because it is for data science because
it has some rich tools from a
mathematics and from a statistical
perspective it has some rich tools so
that is one of the reasons why we use
python and if you see some of the trends
if you're probably tracking some of the
trends you will see that over the last
few years python has become programming
language of choice and especially for
data science sas was earlier one of the
most popular tools but now increasingly
python is being used for doing data
science and of course as well as r one
of the reasons of course is that python
and r are open source compared to sas
which is a commercial product so that
could definitely be one explanation but
beyond that i think it is the ease of
understanding this language the ease of
using this language which is also making
it very popular in addition to the
availability of fantastic libraries for
performing data science what are the
other factors there are speed then there
are availability of number of packages
and then of course the design goal
alright so what are each of these design
goal primarily the syntax rules in
python are relatively
intuitive and easy to understand thereby
it helps in building applications with
the con size and readable code base so
with the few lines of code you can
really achieve a lot of stuff and then
there are a lot of packages that are
available that have been developed by
other people which can be reused so we
don't have to reinvent the wheel and
last but not least the speed so python
is relatively faster language of course
it is not as fast as let's say crc plus
plus but then relatively it is still
faster so these are the three factors
which make python the programming
language of choice so if you want to get
started with python the first thing
obviously is to install python so there
is some documentation there are some
steps that you need to follow so we will
try to briefly touch upon that otherwise
of course there is a lot of material
available on how to install python and
so on you can always look around but
this is one of the again there are
different ways in which you can also
install python so we will use the
anaconda path there is a packaging tool
called anaconda so we will use that path
you can also directly install python but
in our session we will use the anaconda
route so the first thing you need to do
is download anaconda and this is the
path for that and
once you click on this you will come to
a page somewhat like this and download
you can do the corresponding download
based on whether you have a windows or
ubuntu there is a also a download
possible for our package available for
ubuntu if you are doing something on
ubuntu so based on which operating
system in fact this page will
automatically detect which operating
system you are having and it will
actually suggest so for example you see
here if you're running mac os then it
will automatically detect that you have
max and the corresponding installers
will be displayed here similarly if
you're on some flavor of linux like
ubuntu or any other then you will get
the corresponding download links here
and then beyond that you can also select
which version of python you want to
install of course the latest version is
in the three point x
range at the time of recording this 3.6
is one of the latest versions but some
of you may want to do or start with the
earlier version which is python 2.7 to
point x and you can download that as
well if you don't have anything
installed then my suggestion is start
with python 3.6 alright so once you do
that you will be able to install python
and you will be able to run jupyter
notebook okay so now that you know how
to install python and if you have
installed python let's take a look at
what are the various libraries that are
available so python is a very easy
language to
learn and there are some basic stuff
that you can do for example adding or
printing hello world statement and so on
without importing any specific libraries
but if you want to perform data analysis
you need to include or import some
specific libraries so we are going to
talk about those as we move forward so
pandas for example is used for
structured data operations so if you
let's say are performing something on a
csv file you import a csv file create a
data frame and then you can do a lot of
stuffs like data munching and data
preparation before you do any other
stuff like for example machine learning
or so on so that's pandas scipy as the
name suggests it is kind of it provides
more scientific capabilities like for
example it has linear algebra it has
fourier transform and so on and so forth
then you have numpy which is a very
powerful library for performing
n-dimensional or creating n-dimensional
arrays and it also has some of the stuff
that is there in sci-fi like for example
linear algebra and fourier transform and
so on and so forth then you have
matplotlib which is primarily for
visualization purpose it has again very
powerful features for visualizing your
data for doing the initial what is known
as exploratory data analysis for doing
univariate analysis bivariate analysis
so this is extremely useful for
visualizing the data and then psychic
learn is used for performing all the
machine learning activities if you want
to do anything like linear regression
classification or any of this stuff then
the scikit-learn library will be
extremely helpful in addition to that
there are a few other libraries for
example networks and igraph then of
course a very important one is
tensorflow so if you are interested in
doing some deep learning or ai related
stuff then it would be a good idea to
learn about tensorflow and tensorflow is
one of the libraries there is a separate
video on tensorflow you can look for
that and this is a one of the libraries
created by google open source library so
once you're familiar with machine
learning data analysis machine learning
then that may be the next step to go to
deep learning and ai so that's where
tensorflow will be used then you have
beautiful soup which is primarily used
for web scraping and then you take the
data and then analyze and so on then os
library is a very common library as the
name suggests it is for operating system
so if you want to do something on
creating directories or folders and
things like that that's when you would
use os all right so moving on let's talk
in a little bit more detail about each
of these libraries so scipy as the name
suggests is a scientific library and it
very specifically it has some special
functions for integration and for
ordinary differential equations so as
you can see these are mathematical
operations or mathematical functions so
these are readily available in this
library and it has linear algebra
modules and it is built on top of numpy
so we will see what is there in numpy so
this is a again as the name suggests
that num comes from numbers so it is a
mathematical library and one of its key
features is availability of a
n-dimensional array object that is a
very powerful object and we will see how
to use this and then of course you can
create other let's say objects and so on
and
it has tools for integrating with cc
plus plus and also for tran code and
then it of course also has linear
algebra and fourier transformation and
so on all these scientific capabilities
okay what else pandas is another very
powerful library primarily for data
manipulation so
if you're importing any files you will
want to create it like a table so you
will create what is known as data frames
these are very powerful data structures
that are used in python programming so
pandas library provides this capability
and once you import a data import the
data into data frame you can pretty much
do whatever you're doing like in a
regular database so people who are
coming from a database background or sql
background would really like this
because it is very they will feel very
much at home because it feels like
you're using you're viewing a table or
using a table and you can do a lot of
stuff using the pandas library now there
are two important terms or components in
pandas series and the data frame i was
just talking about the data frame so
let's take a look at what are series and
what is a data frame so within pandas we
have series and data frames so series is
primarily some of you may also be
knowing this as let's say an array so
it's a one-dimensional structure data
structure if you will so in some other
languages we may call it as an array or
maybe some others probably an equivalent
of a list in r perhaps i'm not very sure
on that aspect but yes so this is like a
one dimensional storage of information
so that is what is series whereas data
frame is like a table so you have a
two-dimensional structure you have rows
and you have columns and this is very
people as i said who are familiar with
sql and databases will be able to relate
to this very quickly so you have like a
table you have rows and columns and then
you can manipulate the data so if you
want to create a series this is how you
would create a code snippet and as you
can see the programming in python is
very simple there are no major overheads
you just need to import some libraries
whichever essential and then start
creating objects so you don't have to do
additional declaration of variables and
things like that so that is i think one
key difference between python and other
programming languages and what does this
series contain it has to contain these
numbers 6 3 4 6 and x is my object
consisting of the series so if you
display if you just say x it will
display the contents of x and you will
see here that it creates a default index
then you have data frames so if you want
to create a data frame as you can see
the series is like a one-dimensional
structure there is just like a row one
row of items whereas a data frame looks
somewhat like this it is a
two-dimensional structure so you have
columns in one dimension and then you
have rows in the other dimension how do
you create a data frame you need to
create you need to rather import pandas
and then you import in this case we are
basically creating our own data so
that's the reason we are importing numpy
which is one of the libraries we just
referred to a little bit before so we
are using one of the functionalities
within numpy to create some random
numbers otherwise this is not really
mandatory you probably will be importing
the data from outside maybe some csv
file and import into the data frame so
that's what we are doing here so in this
case we are creating our own test data
that's the reason we are importing numpy
as np and then i create a data frame
saying pd dot data frame so this is the
keyword here similarly here in this case
while creating series we said pd dot
series and then you pass the values
similarly here using pd.dataframe now in
order to create the data frame it needs
the values in each of these cells what
are the values in the rows and what are
the values in the column so that in our
example we are providing using this
random number generator so np dot random
is like a class or a method that is
available in numpy and then you are
saying okay generate some random numbers
in the form of a four by three matrix or
four by three data frame the four here
indicates the number of rows and the 3
here indicates the number of columns so
these are the columns 0 1 2 are the
columns and these are the rows here 0
this is 1 this is 2 this is 3 okay and
once again it will when you display df
it will give us a default index there
are ways to omit that but at this point
we will just keep it simple so it will
display the default index and then the
actual values in each of these rows and
columns so this is the way you create a
data frame so now that we have learned
some of the basics of pandas let's take
a quick look at how we use this in real
life so let's assume we have a situation
where we have some customer data and we
want to kind of predict whether the
customer's loan will be approved or not
so we have some historical data about
the loans and about the customers and
using that we will try to come up with a
way to maybe predict whether loan will
be approved or not so let's see how we
can do that so this is a part of
exploratory analysis so we will first
start with exploratory analysis we will
try to see how the data is looking so
what kind of data so we will of course
i'll take you into the jupiter notebook
and give you a quick live demo but
before that let's quickly walk through
some of the pieces of this program in
slides and then i will take you actually
into the actual code and do a demo of
that so the python program structure
looks somewhat like this the first step
is to import your all the required
libraries now of course it is not
necessary that you have to import all
your libraries right at the top of the
code but it is a good practice so if you
know you are going to need a certain set
of libraries it may be a good idea to
put from a readability perspective it's
a good practice to put all the libraries
that you're importing at the beginning
of your call however it is not mandatory
so in the middle of the code somewhere
if you feel that you need a particular
library you can import that library and
then start using it in the middle of the
code so that's also perfectly fine it
will not give any errors or anything
however as i said it's not such a good
practice so we will import all the
required libraries in this case we are
importing pandas numpy and matplotlib
and in addition if we include this piece
of code percentage matplotlib inline
what will happen is all the graphs that
we are going to create the
visualizations that we are going to
create will be displayed within the
notebook so if you want to have that
kind of a provision you need to have
this line so it's always a good idea
when you're starting off i think it's a
good idea to just include this line so
that your graphs are shown in line okay
so these are the four we will start with
these four lines of code then the next
step is to import your data so in our
case there is a training data for loans
by the name loan p underscore train dot
csv and we are reading this data so in
this case you see here unlike the
previous example where we created a data
frame with some data that we created
ourselves here we are actually creating
a data frame using some external data
and it's the method is very very
straightforward so you use the read
underscore csv method and it is a very
intuitive function name and you say pd
dot read underscore csv and give the
path of the file csv file that's about
it and then that is read into the data
frame df this can be any name we are
calling it df you can call xyz anything
there's a name just name of the object
so head is one of the methods within the
data frame and it will give us the first
five so this is just to take a quick
look now you have imported the data you
want to initially have a quick look how
your data is looking what are the values
in some of the columns and so on and so
forth right so typically you would do a
head df dot head to get the sample of
let's say the first few lines of your
data so that's what has happened here so
it displays the first few lines and then
you can see what are the columns within
that and
what are the values in each of these
cells and so on and so forth you can
also typically you would like to see if
there are any null values or are there
any is the data for whatever reason is
invalid or looking dirty for whatever
reason some unnecessary character so
this will give a quick view of that so
in this case pretty much everything
looks okay then the next step is to
understand the data a little bit overall
for each of the columns what is the
information so the describe function
will basically give us a summary of the
data what else can we do pandas also
allows us to visualize the data and this
is more like a part of what we call it
as univariate analysis that means each
and every column you can take and do
some plots and visualization to
understand data in each of the columns
so for example here the loan amount
column we can take and then the hist
basically hist method will create a
histogram so you take all the values
from one column which is loan amount and
you create a histogram to see how the
data is distributed right so that's what
is happening here and as you can see
there are some extreme values so this is
again to identify do we have to do some
data preparation because if the data is
in a completely hazard way the analysis
may be difficult so we these are the
initial or exploratory data analysis is
primarily done to understand that and
see if we need to do some data
preparation before we get into the other
steps like machine learning and
statistical modeling and so on so in
this case we will see that here
by plotting this histogram we see that
there are some extreme values so there
are some values a lot of it is around
100 range but there is also something of
one or two observations in the 700 range
so it's pretty scattered in that sense
or they're not really scattered
distributedly scattered but it is
randomly scattered so the range is
really huge so what can we do about this
so there are some steps that we need to
do normalization and so on so we'll see
that in a bit so this is for one of the
columns let's take another column which
is applicant income similar kind of
similar situation you have most of your
observations in this range but there are
also some which are far off from where
most of the observations are so this is
also pretty this also has some extreme
values so we'll have to see what can be
done credit history is the binary value
so some people have a zero value and
some will have credit history of one
this is just like a flag so this
basically is telling us how many people
have one and how many people have zero
so it looks like majority of them have a
value of one and a few about hundred of
them have a value of zero okay what else
can we do so we now understood a little
bit about the data so we need to do some
data wrangling or data munching and see
if we can some bring in some kind of
normalization of all this data and
we will kind of try to understand what
is data wrangling and before we actually
go into it okay so data wrangling is
nothing but a process of cleaning the
data if let's say there are there are
multiple things that can happen in this
particular example there were no missing
values but typically when you get some
data very often it will so happen that a
lot of values are missing either there
are null values or there are a lot of
zeros now you cannot use such data as it
is to perform some let's say predictive
analysis or perform some machine
learning activities and so on so that is
one part of it so you need to clean the
data the other is unifying the data now
these ranges of this data are very huge
some of them are going from
some columns are going from 0 to 100 000
and some columns are just between 10 to
20 and so on these will affect the
accuracy of the analysis so we need to
do some kind of unifying the data and so
on so that is what wrangling data
wrangling is all about so before we
actually perform any analysis we need to
bring the data so to some kind of a
shape so that we can perform additional
analysis actual analysis on this and get
some insights now how do we deal with
missing values is a very common issue
when we take data or when we get data
from the business when a data scientist
gets the data from the business so we
should never assume that all our data
will be clean and all the values filled
up and so on because in real life very
often there will be the data will be
dirty so data wrangling is the process
where you kind of clean up the data
first of all identify whether the data
is dirty and then clean up so how do we
find some data is missing so there are a
few ways you can write a small piece of
code which will identify if for a given
column or for given row any of the
observations are null primarily so this
line of code for example is doing that
it is trying to identify how many null
values or missing values are there for
each of the columns so this is a lambda
function and what we are saying is find
out if a value is null and then you add
all of them how many observations are
there where this particular column is
null so it does that for all the columns
so here you will see that for loan id
obviously it's an id so there are no
null values or missing values gender has
about 13 observations where the values
are missing similarly marital status has
three and so on and so forth so we'll
see here for example loan amount has 21
observations where the values are
missing loan amount term has 14
observations and so on so we'll see how
to handle this missing values so there
are multiple ways in which you can
handle missing values if the number of
observations are very small compared to
the total number of observations then
sometimes one of the easy ways is to
completely remove that data so or delete
that record exclude that record so that
is one way of doing it so if there are
let's say a million records and maybe 10
records are having missing values it may
not be
worth doing something to fill up those
values it may be better off to get rid
of those observations right so that is
the missing values are proportionately
very small but if there are relatively
large number of missing values if you
exclude those observations then your
accuracy may not be that very good so
the other way of doing it is we can take
a mean value or for a particular column
and fill up wherever there are missing
values fill up those observations or
cells with the mean value so that way
what happens is you don't give some
value which is too high or too low and
it somehow fits within the range of the
observations that we are seeing so this
is one technique again there are it can
be case to case and you may have to take
a call based on your specific situation
but these are some of the common method
if you see in the previous case loan
amount had 21 and now we went ahead and
filled all of those with the mean value
so now there are zero with missing
values okay so this is one part of a
data wrangling activity what else you
can do you can also check what are the
types of the data so df.d types will
give us what are the various data types
so all right so you can also perform
some basic mathematical observations we
have already seen that mean we found out
so similarly if you do call the mean
method for the data frame object it will
actually perform or display or calculate
the mean for pretty much all the
numerical columns that are available in
this right so for example here applicant
income co applicant income and all these
are numerical values so it will display
the main values of all of those now
another thing that you can do is you can
actually also combine data frames so
let's say you import data from one csv
file into one data frame and another csv
file into another data frame and then
you want to merge these because you want
to do an analysis on the entire data
okay one example could be that you have
data in the form of csv files one csv
file for each month of the year january
february march each of these are in a
different so you can import them into
let's say 12 data frames and then you
can merge them together as a single data
frame and then you perform your analysis
on the entire data frame or the entire
data for the year so that is one example
so how do we do that this is how we do
again in this case we are not importing
any data we are just creating some
random values or using some random
values so let's assume i have a data
frame which is by the name one and i
assign some random values here which is
a five by four format so there are five
rows and four columns and this is how my
data frame one looks and then i create
another data frame which is data frame
two again random numbers of the format
five by four and i have something like
this now i want to combine these two how
do i combine these two i can use the
concatenate or concat method and i can
combine these two so pd dot concat and
it takes the the data frames one and two
if you have more of them you can provide
them and it will just simply add all of
them merge all of them or concatenate
whatever you call whichever term you
call
it will so of course we have to make
sure that the structure remains the same
like i said this could be let's say
sales data coming for 12 different
months but each of the files has the
same structure so now you can combine
all of them merge all of them by using
the concat method if we
have let's say structure is not
identical then what will happen let's
say we have these two data frames one
has a column by the name key and the
second column is lval and a second data
frame which has a column by the name key
but the second column by the name arval
not l val so you see here the structure
is not identical so you can still
combine them but then the way they get
combined or merged is somewhat like this
so it takes the key as a common
parameter between them some common
column has to be there otherwise this
will not work and then we have to use
merge instead of concatenate and when we
do a merge then we get the result will
be in this format what it does is it
uses the key as a common thread between
them and then it kind of populates the
values accordingly so if you see here
the first one had fu and bar for key and
then it had l values of one and two
right so if we go back foo and bar had
one and two l values so that's what we
see here one and two whereas in the
right data frame we had foo bar and bar
as a second time and then our values are
three 4 and 5. so what it has done for
foo it has put for the existing right
for 4 is already existing because it has
come from left so it will just put the
value of r while here which is 3.
similarly it will put 4 here because for
bar if you go back for bar it is the
value is 4 and since it has one more
value of bar it will go and add this 5
as well the only thing here is that this
one had for example left had only two
values and only one value for bar but
since we are appending or merging and
there are two key values with the bar
therefore it will kind of repeat the
value of l val here so that's what we
are seeing in this case right so l value
appears twice the number 2 appears twice
but that is because r value there are
two of them okay all right so that is
how when you don't have identical
structure that's how you merge now we
will talk a little bit about
scikit-learn so scikit-learn is a
library which is used for doing machine
learning over for performing machine
learning activities so if you want to do
linear regression logistic regression
and so on there are easily usable apis
that you can call and that's
the advantage of scikit-learn and it
provides a bunch of algorithms so i
think that is the good part about this
library so if you want to use
scikit-learn obviously you need to
import these modules and also there are
some sub-modules you may have to import
based on what you're trying to use like
for example if we know if we want to use
logistic regression again people who are
probably not very familiar with machine
learning there is a separate module for
machine learning you may want to take a
look at that but we will just touch upon
the basics here so machine learning has
some algorithms like linear regression
logistic regression and random forest
classification and so on so that is what
we are talking about here so those
algorithms are available and when if you
want to use some of them you need to
import them and from the scikit-learn
library so scikit-learn is the top-level
library which is basically sklearn right
and then it has a kind of subparts in it
you need to import those based on what
exactly you will be or which algorithm
you will be using so let's take an
example as we move and we will see that
whenever we perform some machine
learning activity those of you who are
familiar with machine learning will
already know this we split our labeled
data into two parts training and test
now there are multiple ways of splitting
this data how do we either some people
do it like 50 50 some people do it 80 20
which is training is 80 and test it is
20 and so on so it is individual
preference there are no hard and fast
rules by and large we have seen that
training data set is larger than the
test data set and again we will probably
not go into details of why do we do this
at this point but that's one of the
steps in machine learning so psychic
scikit-learn offers a readily available
method to do this which is drain test
split all right so in this example let's
say we are taking the values x and y are
our values x is the independent
variables and y is our dependent
variable okay and we are using these two
and then i want to split this into train
and test data so what do we do we import
the train test split sub module from
within scikit learn which is sklearn
right so within that we import drain
test split and then you call the strain
test split method or function or
whatever you call it and pass the data
so x is the all the values of the
independent variables and y is our
labels so you pass x and y and then you
specify what should be your size of the
test data so only one you need to
specify so if you say test size is 0.25
it is understood that train size will be
0.75 so you're telling what should be
the ratio of the split so technically it
doesn't nothing prevents you from giving
whatever you like here so you can give
test as 80 and train as 20 so whichever
way but then this normal practices you
will have the training data set would be
larger than the test data set and
typically it would be 80 20 75 25 or 65
35 something like that right so that is
the second parameter and this is just to
say that you know the data has to be
randomly split so it shouldn't be like
you take the first 75 percent and put it
in training and then the next 25 percent
and put it in test so that so such a
thing shouldn't happen so we first set
the state random state so that the the
splitting is done in a very random way
so they randomly picked up the data and
then put it into training and test and
then this results in these four data
frames so x train and x test and y train
and y test okay so that is basically the
result it will
now that the splitting is done let's see
how to implement or execute logistic
regression so in logistic regression
what we try to do is try to develop a
model which will classify the data
logistic regression is an algorithm for
supervised learning for performing
classification so logistic regression is
for classification and usually it is
binary classification so binary
classification means there are two
classes so either like a yes no or for
example customer will buy or will not
buy so that is a binary classification
so that's where we use logistic
regression so let's take a look at the
code how to implement something like
that using scikit learn so the first
thing is to import this logitech
regression sub module or subclass
whatever you call it and then create an
instance of that so our object is
classifier so we are creating an object
by the name this is a name by the way
you can give any name in our case we are
saying classifier we say classifier is
equal to logistic regression so we are
creating an instance of the logistic
regression variable or class or whatever
okay and you can pass a variable or a
parameter rather which is the random
state is equal to 0 and once you create
the object which in our case is named
classifier you can then train the object
by calling the method fit so this is
important to note we don't call any
there is no method like train here but
we call what is known as there is a
method called fit so you are basically
by calling the fit method you are
training
this model and
in order to train the model you need to
pass the training data set so x
underscore train is your independent
variables the set of independent
variables and y underscore train is your
dependent variable or the label so you
pass both of these and call the fit
function or fit method which will
actually result in the training of this
model classifier now this is basically
showing what are the possible parameters
that can be passed or initiated when we
are calling the logistic or the instance
of logistic regression so this is but
you can also look up the help file if
you have installed python so some of
these are very intuitive but some you
may want to take a look at the details
of what exactly they do all right so
moving on once we train the model by
calling fit then the next step is to
test our model so this is where we will
use the test data you need to pay
attention here here i am calling so
there are two things one is in order to
test our data we have to actually call
what is known as the method known as
predict right so here this is where so
the training is done now is the time for
inference isn't it so we have the model
now we want to check whether our model
is working correctly or not so what do
you do you have your test data remember
we split it 25 percent of our data was
stored here right we split it into test
and training so that 25 of the data we
pass to and call the method predict so
that the model will now predict the
values for y right so that's why here we
are calling it as y underscore predict
and um if we display here as i said this
is the logistic regression which is
basically binary classification so it
gives us the results like yes or no in
this particular case and then you can so
this is what the model has predicted our
model has classified now but we also
know we already have the labels for this
so we need to compare with the existing
labels with the known labels whether
this classification is correct or not so
that is where is the next step which is
basically calculating the accuracy and
so on will come into play okay so in
this case the first thing most important
thing to note is we do the prediction
using predict and here we are passing x
underscore test and not train right in
this case we did x and y ten so again
one more point to be noted here in case
of training we will pass both the
independent variables and also the
dependent variables because the system
has to internally it has to verify that
is what is the training process so what
it will do it will take the x values it
will try to come up with the y value and
compare with the actual y value right so
that is what is the training method so
that's why we have to pass both x as
well as y whereas in case of predict we
don't pass both we only pass because we
are pretending as if this is the actual
data so in actual data you will not have
the labels isn't it so we are just
passing the independent variables and
the system will then come up with the y
values which we will then okay remember
we also know the actual value so we will
compare this with the actual values and
we will find out whether how accurate
the model is so how do we do that we use
what is known as a confusion matrix so
this is also readily available in the
python library so we import this
confusion matrix and some of you who
already know machine learning will find
this familiar but those who are new to
machine learning this confusion matrix
is nothing but this matrix this kind of
a matrix which basically tells how many
of them are correctly predicted and how
many of them are incorrectly predicted
so the some of the characteristics let's
quickly spend some time on this
confusion matrix itself this the total
numbers out here these are just the
numbers these are like number of
observations then the accuracy is
considered to be highest when the the
numbers or the sum of the numbers across
the diagonals is maximum okay and the
numbers outside of the diagonal should
be minimum so which means that if this
model was 100 accurate then the sum of
these two there would have been only
numbers in these two along the diagonal
this would have been zero and this would
have been zero okay so that is like a
hundred percent accurate model that is
very rare but just that you are aware so
just to give an idea okay all right so
once you have the confusion matrix you
then try to calculate the accuracy which
is in a percentage so there are two
things that we can do from a confusion
matrix or that we can calculate from a
confusion matrix one is the accuracy and
the other is the precision what is the
accuracy accuracy is basically a measure
of how many of the observations have
been correctly predicted okay so let's
say this is a little bit more detailed
view of the confusion matrix it looks
very similar like as we saw in this case
right so this is a two by two matrix
that's what we're seeing here 18 27 2 1
0 3 so 18 27 2 1 0 3. now but what are
these values that is what is kind of the
labels are shown here in this so there
are altogether 150 observations so as i
said the sum of all these four right 18
plus 27 plus 103 plus 2 is equal to 150
that's the first thing we have to
observe the sum of all these values will
be equal to the sum of test observations
number of test observations we have 150
test observations because remember we
had about 500 we split that into 2575 so
that is why we have 150 here and i think
350 in the training data set okay so
that we get the numbers correct so
that's the first thing now this next
thing is let's take a look at the actual
values this view is the actual view so
there are actually right in the actual
data we have labels yes and no so as per
the actual data there are 45
observations tagged as no and similarly
there are 105 observations that are
tagged as yes or labeled as yes okay now
i know for the first time when you're
seeing this it may be a little confusing
but just stay with me okay so this is
the actual part of it and this side
tells us the predicted part of it so our
model is predicted and it has totally
predicted 20 of them as no right so that
is what this is totally 20 of them it
has predicted as no and it has predicted
130 of them as yes okay i hope this part
is clear so before we go into the middle
part let us first understand what
exactly are these numbers so actually
tagged as no there are 45 total actually
tagged as yes there are 105 and
predicted no there are 20 predicted as
yes there are 130. this is the result
from our model okay this is the result
from our model and this is the actual
value which we already know because this
is our label data that's the first thing
now now let us take a look at each of
these individually okay now what are the
options we have once again okay so now
what is happening here let us look at
these these values so this 18 says that
these are actually tagged as no and the
model is also predicted as no which
means this is what is known as a true
positive right or true negative sorry
right which means that our model as
predicted is it correctly it is negative
because it says no so and it is also
predicted no so it is known as what is
known as true negative okay now let's
come to this side of it that way we are
talking about the diagonal remember i
said most of the values should be in the
diagonal okay so that means these 18 are
correctly tagged they are labeled as no
and our model is predicted as no so
these are correctly tagged and these are
known as true negative okay similarly if
we come diagonally down there are 103
observations which are labeled as yes
actual value is s and our model is also
predicted as yes and these are known as
true positive values positive because of
this yes okay right so what is important
is this is true this is also true so we
have to make sure that the maximum
number of values are in the true section
okay true positive and true negative
that's the reason i said the sum along
the diagonal should be maximum now let's
see if our model was 100 accurate this
sum in this case it is only 103 plus 103
plus 18 which is
121 but if our model was accurate the
sum of these two would have been 150
that means it's a perfect model okay all
right now what else since we covered
these two let's also cover these two so
here this says that 27 of them were
actually labeled no but our model is
predicted as yes that means this is
wrong right similarly these are two of
them where the actual value is yes but
our model is predicted as no that means
it's a wrong prediction so you get the
point so therefore along the diagonals
are the correct values whereas in other
places it is all wrong values or wrong
predictions okay now how do we calculate
accuracy from this information so the
way to calculate accuracy is so we'd say
okay there are total observations are
150 and what are the correctly predicted
values these are the correctly predicted
values which is 18 plus 103. so this
will give us our accuracy so 103 plus 18
which is 121 divided by our total
observations which is 150 is our
accuracy which is 0.8 or we can say it
is 80 percent okay now there is another
concept called precision so appreciation
is given by the formula true positives
divided by the predicted positives
totally predicted positives okay what do
we mean by that which are the true
positives here remember which are the
true positives we just recall we just
talked in the previous slide which are
the true positives you see here so this
103 are the true positives which means
that the value is positive actual value
is positive predicted value is also
positive so that's why it's called a
true positive so 103 divided by so that
is our true positive 103 divided by
totally predicted as yes now what is
totally predicted is yes remember 130 of
them have altogether been predicted as
yes not that they are correctly
predicted only 103 have been correctly
predicted but 130 of them have been
predicted as yes so precision is
basically the ratio of these two out of
the totally predicted how many of them
are actually true that ratio so 103 by
130 which is again about 80 percent is
the precision that's how you calculate
precision so this is just a simple
formula and the term that you need to
remember so accuracy is you need to take
total of true positive and true negative
divided by the total number of
observations whereas precision is true
positives divided by the totally
predicted positives okay so that is our
accuracy and precision now what we did
the accuracy calculation was manual but
we can also use some libraries which are
already existing and the functions
within that library so a scikit-learn
provides one such method so for example
accuracy underscore score is one such
method so if you use that and pass your
test and predicted values only the y you
need to pass right the dependent
variable values so if you pass that it
will calculate it for you so in this
case again as you can see it still
calculates the same which is 80 which we
have seen here as well okay so this can
be done using the method great so that's
pretty much what we have done here
before we conclude let me take you into
the code and show you how it actually
looks okay so
this is our code let me run it okay one
by one we have already seen most of the
steps in the slides so i will but i will
run this in the actual jupyter notebook
some of you if you are not yet familiar
with jupiter notebook again there are
other videos we created on how to
install jupiter notebook and how to set
up jupyter notebook and so on in this
tutorial also we there was one slide on
how to install python and jupyter
notebook if you have not yet done please
do that so that then you can actually
walk through this code while you're
watching this okay so what are we doing
here we are importing the libraries
required libraries recall here we have
pandas we have numpy and for
visualization we have matplotlib and
this line is basically reading the csv
file so we have the csv file locally on
our local drive and this is where i'm
checking the data just so that i'm
starting with my exploratory analysis
how the data is looking so it looks good
there are no major missing values or
anything like that so it will display
all the columns and it will show me the
first five rows if when i'm using this
head function and then i want to see a
kind of a summary of all the each of the
numerical columns so that's what i'm
doing here so these are the numerical
columns and it gives a summary like how
many observations are there what is the
mean standard deviation minimum maximum
and so on and so forth for each of them
and then you can do some visualization
so this is the
visualization for this okay the next
step is to
view the data data visualization and we
will do that using a histogram for a
couple of these columns so in this case
i'm taking a look at the loan amount and
if i create a histogram it displays the
data here in the form of a histogram one
thing that we gather from this as i
mentioned in the slides as well as how
the data is kind of scattered so while
most of the values are in this range 0
to 300 range there are a few extreme
values around the 700 range so that is
one information we get from this
histogram similarly for the applicant
income if we draw a histogram something
similar we can see that while most of
the values are in this range 0 to 20 000
range there are a few in the range of 80
000 and probably 65 000 and so on okay
so the next step is to perform data
wrangling where we will check if any
data is missing and how to fill those
missing values and so on so in this case
we will just check for all the columns
how many data or how many entries are
there with missing values so this is the
results loan id has all the columns or
all the cells filled gender has 13
missing values marital status has three
missing values and so on and so forth
loan amount has 21 and this is what we
are going to show you how to remove
these missing values so when you have
missing values as i mentioned in the
during the slides there are a couple of
ways of handling that one is you can
completely remove those or you fill in
with some meaningful values so in this
case we will fill the missing values
with the mean value of the loan amount
so let's go ahead and do that and
now if we check here now loan amount
number of missing values is 0 because
what we did was for all these 21 cells
where the values were missing we filled
with the mean value of the loan amount
so now there are no more missing values
for loan amount we can do this for other
columns as well but this was just one
example so we have shown it here okay so
we will run this for credit history and
loan amount term as well and
then if we calculate the mean of pretty
much all the numerical columns that's
the method call so df.mean will give us
the mean of all the numerical values and
another thing that we can do is we want
to find out what are the data types of
each of these columns so you can call
df.d types and get the data types of
course it may not be that very useful
most of the cases is an object but for
example this one it shows as int64 and
there are float64 and so on and so forth
now in addition to doing the
exploratory data analysis we can do some
machine learning activity as well so in
this case we are going to do logistic
regression so this is the example that i
have shown you in the slides as well
this is the actual code for that all
right so the first step here is to
import the libraries and then the next
step is to separate the independent
variables and the dependent variables so
x is our independent variable and y is
our dependent variable so we separate
the data into two parts and this will be
our target as well right so that's how
we separate it now we have to split the
data into training and test data sets as
i mentioned in the during the slides we
use the train test split method and when
we call this and pass the independent
variables and the dependent variables
and we specify the test size to be 0.25
which means the training size will be
0.75 which is nothing but you split the
data into training data set which is 75
percent and test data set in which is 25
okay so once you split that you will
have all your independent variables data
in x strain the training data which is
75 percent of it similarly independent
variables for test will be in x
underscore test and dependent variable
strain will be in underscore train and
dependent variable test will be y
underscore test once we do this we have
to do a small exercise for scaling
remember we had some data which was kind
of very scattered there were some
extreme values and so on so this will
take care of that so that the data is
normalized so that before we pass to our
algorithm the data is normalized so that
the performance will be much better the
next step is to create the instance of
logistic regression object so that's
what we are doing here so classifier is
our logistic regression instance right
classifier is equal to logistic
regression we are saying so one instance
of logic regression is created and then
we call the training method the name of
the method actually is fit but what it
is doing is it is taking the training
data x is the training data or the
independent variables and y is the
dependent variable so we are taking both
of these and the model gets trained so
the method for calling the training is
fit okay so it gives us the output and
then once we are done with the training
we do the testing and once again just to
recall in the slides when i was showing
you the slides also i mentioned we don't
pass y here while we are testing while
for training we do pass y but right so
for fit we are passing x and y but for
test we are only passing x something you
need to observe because y will be
calculated by the model and we will then
compare that with the known value of y
to measure the accuracy so that's what
we will do here and the method that is
called here is predict so this will
basically create or predict the values
of y now we have in this case a binary
classification so the outputs are yes or
no y indicates yes and n indicates no so
y or n is the output now how do we
measure the accuracy as we have seen
earlier i described how confusion matrix
works and how we can use confusion
matrix for calculating the accuracy
that's what we are seeing here so this
is the confusion matrix and then you
want to do the measure the accuracy you
can directly use this method and we find
that it is 80 so we in the slides we
have seen when we calculate manually as
well we get an accuracy of 80 okay let's
go back to our slides and
do a summary so what we have done in the
session we talked about what is data
science and
why python is being used why it is
becoming so popular how to install
python and we talked about the various
libraries in python like pandas scipy
numpy and so on and then we took a
couple of examples
and wrote the code and demonstrated the
code for performing exploratory analysis
and
performing data wrangling or data
manipulation
and then we at the end we did one
example of machine learning using
scikit-learn
library and perform the logistic
regression example
welcome to data science interview
questions my name is richard kirschner
with the simply learn team that's
www.simplylearn.com get certified get
ahead before we dive in and start going
through the questions one at a time
we're going to start with some of the
logical kind of concept that's enters in
a lot of interviews and this one you
have two buckets one of three leaders
and the other five leaders you're
expected to measure exactly four leaders
how will you complete the task and no
you only have the two buckets you don't
have a third bucket or anything like
that just the two buckets and the object
of the question like this is to see how
well you are thinking outside the box in
this case you're in a larger box you
have two buckets and also the pattern
which you go on and what that means is
if you look at the two buckets and we'll
show you their answer in just a second
you have a bucket with three liters and
a bucket with five liters and the first
thought is what happens if you go from
left to right so we have a direction and
what happens if you pour the three
liters into the five liter bucket well
if you pour the three liters into five
liter bucket you have an empty bucket of
three liters and what's really important
here is i was thinking outside the box
you realize that you have a five liter
bucket that has three liters in it and
two empty leaders so you have two
additional leaders you can fill up if we
continue that process we can pour from
the left to right from the small bucket
to the large bucket you can now measure
in two additional liters into the five
liter bucket and three minus two is one
and you can keep doing that you can
empty the five liter bucket in pour
those three liters in that one liter in
and then you can pour three liters in
what's cool about these questions as you
explore them is you realize there's
multiple ways usually to solve i went
from small bucket to big bucket the
simply learned team their solution that
they pulled out was you fill the five
liter bucket and empty it into the three
liter bucket now you're left with two
liters in the five liter bucket so
that's great we can empty the three
liter bucket so now we're going from
large to small remember we went from
small to large so you can go both either
way but you have to go one way or the
other it turns out and you can empty the
three liter bucket and pour the contents
of the five liter bucket in it so the
three liter bucket now has two liters
and if it has two liters that means it
has an empty one liter and by now you
probably have guessed that if you have
an empty space you can start using that
empty space of one liter as a measuring
so we fill the five liter bucket again
and we pour the water in the three liter
bucket it already has the two liters and
so we're only pouring one liter in there
and five minus one is four so interview
questions they break up into all kinds
of different patterns we have logic like
this one which is a lot of fun we have
questions that come up that are more
vocabulary list the difference between
supervised and unsupervised learning
probably one of the fundamental
breakdowns in
data science and supervised learning
uses known and labeled data as input
supervised learning has a feedback
mechanism most commonly used supervised
learning algorithms are decision tree
logistic regression support vector
machine and you should know that those
are probably the most common use right
now and there certainly are so many
coming out so that's a very evolving
thing and be aware of a lot of the
different algorithms that are out there
outside of the deep learning because a
lot of these work faster on raw data
numbers than they do than a deep neural
network would unsupervised learning uses
unlabeled data as input unsupervised
learning has no feedback mechanism most
commonly used unsupervised learning
algorithms are k-means clustering
hierarchical clustering the appropriate
algorithm and there certainly are more
i'm going to say k-means definitely is
at the top of the list and the
hierarchical clustering those two are
used so many times so really important
to understand what those are and how
they're used and most important is
understand that supervised learning is
you have your data set where you have
training data and you have all those
different pieces moving around but you
you're able to train it you know the
answers and unsupervised we're just
grouping things together that look like
they go together how is logistic
regression done logistic regression
measures the relationship between the
dependent variable our label what we
want to predict and the one or more
independent variables are features by
estimating probability using its
underlying logistic function sigmoid and
whenever i draw these charts i always
end up drawing them the right hand side
first because you want to know what your
output is what is you want out of here
and the left hand side what do you have
going in so you have your in and out you
can see we have a nice labeled image
here to help you remember this we have
our inputs we have our linear model we
have our probabilities what are the
probabilities of it being a certain way
based on these features coming in the
sigmoid function and it's important to
note that the sigmoid function is maybe
the most commonly used but it's only one
of a number of functions that are out
there and the sigmoid function turns our
probabilities into a value between 0 and
1 or very close to 0 very close to 1
between 0.1 and 0.009 and based on that
we generate an answer in this case is
zero or one how is logistic regression
done so last time we talked about the
sigmoid function generally depending on
what your interview and level of math
and what expertise you're going in for
the market you'll have to understand
that formula of the probability equals 1
over 1 plus e to the negative y and
that's e to the base 2. so you have your
probability function or your sigmoid
function which pushes it as you can see
we have a nice visual of that that helps
a lot to have that visual on the sigmoid
function you definitely should know your
y equals m times x plus c your base
euclidean geometry of forming a line in
the slope plus the intercept the y
intercept and then you have your natural
log and the natural log is to the e as
opposed to a base two or base ten so
your natural log to the e of the
probability over one minus a probability
equals your m times x plus c or your
euclidean line that helps a lot as far
as the graphing and understanding the
sigmoid function so we'll just keep
pushing on to question number three
explain the steps in making a decision
tree and i noticed last time we brought
up the decision tree in the forest a lot
of questions came up what is the
difference so let's go through that when
you make a decision tree you're going to
take the entire data set as input you're
going to calculate entropy of the target
variable as well as the predictor
attributes i remember entropy is just
how chaotic is it so if you have like
you know banana and grapes and oranges
if you're mixing in fruit and that's
your data coming in you have all these
different objects that are so separate
from each other and the more they become
uniform the lower the entropy and we
call that information gain so we gain
information on sorting different objects
from each other so you have your entropy
you have to calculate your information
gain of all attributes and then you
choose the attribute with the highest
information gain as the root node so if
you can separate your group and each
group chaos in each group is lowered
whichever split lowers the chaos the
most that's where you split it and
that's your root node at that point you
repeat the same procedure on every
branch till the decision node of each
branch finalized so understanding that
setup is pretty important as far as
decision trees and you can see here we
have a nice visual of a decision tree
for example if you want to build a
decision tree to decide whether we
should accept or decline a job offer
since these are interview questions
that's a good one to ask and just as a
tip you should be pretty aware of the
formula for entropy and information gain
so you need to look those up if you
don't remember those and the salary if
it's greater than 50 000 no decline the
offer yes it's got a good salary the
commute is greater than an hour yes
decline the offer no offers incentives
yes except the offer no incentives
decline the offer so we use decision
tree pretty much for everything if you
want and if you have a decision tree
then you also should understand how do
you build a random forest model and
remember that a random forest is built
up of a number of decision trees so if
you split your date up into a lot of
different packages and you do a decision
tree on each of those different groups
of data the random forest is bringing
all those trees together so how do you
build a random forest model randomly
select k features from a total of m
features where k is less than m among
the k features calculate the node d
using the best split point split the
node into daughter nodes using the best
split repeat steps 2 and 3 steps until
leaf nodes are finalized build for us by
repeating steps one to four for end
number times to create in number of
trees so you can see it's got the same
build pattern as the tree but instead
you're building a number of different
trees little small trees so it all have
an n leaf node random forest has a vote
at the end and whoever gets the most
votes wins that's the answer how can you
avoid overfitting of your model very
important question in any kind of
mathematical scientific data science
setup in any of them there are three
main methods to avoid overfitting and
you should really understand overfitting
overfitting means that your model is
only set for a very small amount of data
and ignores the bigger picture keep the
model simple take into account fewer
variables thereby removing some of the
noise in the training data good advice
for any programming at all use
cross-validation techniques such as
k-folds cross-validation use
regularization techniques such as lasso
that penalize certain model parameters
if they're likely to cause overfitting
and you should also be well aware that
your cross validation techniques that's
like a pre data or your lasso and your
regularization techniques are usually
during the process so when you're
prepping your data that's when you're
gonna do a cross validation such as like
splitting your data into three groups
and you train it on two groups and test
it on one and then switch which two
groups you tested on that kind of thing
so can you solve another one of these i
love these things there are nine balls
out of which one ball is heavy in weight
and the rest are of the same weight and
how many minimum weighings will you find
the heavier ball and when we say
weighing think of a scale where you can
put objects on one side and the other
and you can see which side is heavier
and you want to minimize that you want
to split the balls up in such a way that
you're going to do as few measurements
as you can you will need to perform two
wangs so you can get it down to just two
wings and i always think if there's nine
balls and divide them into three groups
of three place three balls on each side
so you can just randomly pick six of the
balls and three on one side three on the
other and if they balance out both sides
are equal then you know the heavy weight
isn't in any of those so out of the
remaining three balls from step one take
two balls and place one ball on each
side
a little tricky there because i always
want to put all three i want to put two
on one side and one on the other but no
just take randomly pick two of those put
one on each side if they balance out
then the left out ball the one you
didn't measure will be the heavier one
otherwise you'll see it in the balance
you'll see which one's heavier because
it'll take one of the balls down now we
go to scenario b where they did not
balance out so now we know which side
has a heavier ball in it and it's just
very similar to what we did before if
the balls in step one do not balance out
then take those three balls that have
the heavier side on them and reproduce
step two to find out the heavier ball
difference between univariate bivariate
and multivariate analysis and hopefully
if you know a little latin you'll kick
in there that you have uni and you have
bi and you have multi because the answer
is in the words themselves so the first
one this type of data contains only one
variable so let's see univariate purpose
of the univariate analysis is to
describe the data and find patterns that
exist within it so when you only see one
one variable coming in in this case
we're using height of students you're
limited as far as what you can do with
that data so you can come up and draw
different patterns and conclusions from
those patterns using the means the
median the mode dispersion range minimum
maximum so we're describing the data so
all those words would describe the data
and that's about all you can do with
them data like that there's no
correlation there's nothing to go beyond
that as far as guessing or predicting
anything so we move into bivariate you
know uni means one by means two
bivariate this type of data involves two
different variables the analysis of this
type of data deals with causes and
relationships and the analysis is done
to find out the relationship among the
two variables and this is always a
favorite one because everybody loves ice
cream in the summer when it's hot and
very few people go for ice cream in the
winter when it's really cold so it's
easy to see the correlation in the data
the temperature and ice cream cells in
summer season and you can see here where
the temperature goes from 20 to 35 and
as the temperature goes up so does the
sales of ice cream it goes from 2 000
i'm not sure 2 000 what's i'm guessing
it's a very large chain because if
they're selling 2 000 ice cream cones
and they have a lot of business good for
them a little vendor on the corner
selling 2 000 ice cream cones a day and
3 100 the next day here the relationship
is visible from the table that
temperature and cells are directly
proportional to each other so the hotter
the temperature we can predict an
increase in cells so the word prediction
should come up so we have description
and prediction when the data involves
three or more variables it is
categorized under multivariate it is
similar to bivariate but contains more
than one dependent variable in this
example another really common one the
data for house price prediction the
patterns can be studied by drawing
conclusions using mean median and mode
dispersion or range minimum maximum etc
and so you can start describing the data
that's what all that was and then using
that description to guess what the price
is going to be so this is very good if
you're in the market and you have
already looked at the area and you
already know that a two bedroom zero
floor 900 square foot house is usually
runs about 40 000 you can guess what the
next one that looks similar to it is and
i'll just throw in another word in there
i don't see very often unless you're
really a hardcore data science we talked
about describing the data descriptive we
talked about predictive and there's also
post postscriptive postscriptive means
we're going to change the variables to
try to guess what the outcome is if we
change what's going on so that would be
the next step but that usually doesn't
show up unless you're dealing with some
really hardcore data science groups what
are the feature selection methods to
select the right variables there are two
main methods for feature selection
there's filter methods and wrapper
methods and when you're filtering your
before we discuss the two methods real
quick the best analogy for
selecting features is bad data in bad
answer out so when we're limiting or
selecting our features it's all about
cleaning up the data coming in so it's
cleaner and is more representative of
what we're trying to predict filter
method filter methods as they come in we
have linear discrimination analysis
anova chi squared chi square is probably
the most common one and these are all
part of pre-processing we're taking out
all the outliers all the things that
have a difference that is very different
from the data we're looking at the odd
ones and sometimes you take the odd ones
out and then you analyze them separately
to see why they're odd but remember your
filter methods you want to pull all that
weird stuff out wrapper methods on the
other hand our forward selection
backward selection recursive feature
elimination and one of the most
important things remember about wrapper
methods is they're very labor-intensive
you have to have some pretty high-end
computers if you're doing a lot of data
analysis with the wrapper method and
just quickly forward selection means you
have all your different features they're
off to the side and we test just one
feature at a time we keep adding them in
until we get a good fit backwards we
have all the features and we start we
run a test on that to see how well it
does and then we start removing features
to see what works and recursive which is
the most processing hungry algorithm out
there goes through and just recursively
looks through all the different features
and how they pair together but again we
have filter method and wrapper method
and it's important to understand that
we're sorting the data out and finding
out which features are going to
represent the data the best and which
ones are not going to really add any
value to our models
let's jump number eight in your choice
of language write a program that prints
the numbers from 1 to 50. but for
multiples of 3 print fizz instead of the
number and for the multiples of 5 print
abuzz for numbers which are multiples of
both
3 and 5 print fizz buzz and this really
is testing your knowledge and iterating
over data very important my sister who
runs at the university the data science
team is in charge of their department
the first question she asks in her
interview of anybody who comes in is how
do they iterate through data so if this
question comes up a lot and it's very
important you have an understanding and
there's actually a slight error on this
code which i'll point out in just a
second the concept is we have fizz buzz
in range you have range 51 which in this
case goes from 0 to 51 and i'm gonna
challenge you to see if you can catch
the error and i'll tell you at the end
of the code where the error is what that
means is that we're going to go through
all the numbers 0 1 2 3 4 and we're
going to process through this loop if
the remainder of fizzbuzz divided by
three equals zero and fizzbuzz divided
by five also equals zero then print
fizzbuzz continue and else if fizzbuzz
divided by three equals zero then print
fizz print fizz continue else if is buzz
divided by five equals zero print buzz
continue and print fizzbuzz you fit the
print the answer in this case fizzbuzz
is either gonna be the number we
generated which is zero or it'll be the
fizz buzz fizz or buzz
that's a mouthful now if you didn't
catch the error in the code which is
always a fun game find the error it has
to do with the range and it's important
to remember the range here says range to
51 that's 0 to 51 which is is correct we
want to go to 51 because it stops it
gets to 50 and it stops so that's 0 to
50. but if you remember the question
asked from 1 to 50. so the range should
be 1 comma 51 not just 51 which does 0
to 51. in this particular script in
python you could leave out the continue
but the continue in this script skips
the next lsf so it doesn't keep
processing it going down and in
programming a lot of scripts you don't
need the continuance this would depend
on what script you chose and there's
probably some other ways to do this it's
a lot of fun and you can see here from
the output we end up with fizz buzz for
zero which shouldn't be there one two
fizz four buzz fizz seven eight fizz
buzz eleven fizz and so on sounds like a
drinking game from my college days so
long ago many decades ago you are given
a data set consisting of variables
having more than 30 percent missing
values how will you deal with them oh
the joy of messy data coming in ways to
handle missing data values data set is
huge we can just simply remove the rows
with missing data values there's the
quickest way i.e we use the rest of the
data to predict the values you just go
in there and say any row of our data
that has a n a in it get rid of it that
doesn't work with smaller data so a
smaller data you start running into
problems because you lose a lot of data
and so we can substitute missing values
with the mean or average of the rest of
the data using pandas data frame in
python there's different ways to do this
obviously in different languages and
even in python there's different ways to
do this but in python it's real easy you
can do the df.mean so you get the mean
value so if you set mean equal to that
then you can do a df.fill in a with the
mean value very easy to do in a python
panda script and if you're using python
you should really know pandas and numpy
number python and pandas data frames for
the given points how will you calculate
the euclidean distance in python so back
to our basic algebra from high school
euclidean distance is the line on the
triangle and so if we're given the
points plot one equals one comma three
plot two equals two comma five we know
that from this we can take the
difference of each one of those points
square them and then take the square
root of everything so the euclidean
distance equals the square root of plot
1 0 minus plot 2 is 0 squared plus plus
1 of 1 minus plot 2 of 1 squared
mouthful there and you can remember if
you have multiple dimensions that go
past two dimensions you could have plot
three can simply be the distance from
plot one you only need to do one side of
that or plot two you can do either way
and square that and take the square root
of that another mind bender how to
calculate some how to figure out the
solution to something what is the angle
between the hour and minute hands of a
clock when the time is halfed past six
so you want to kind of imagine that
clock where the large hand is pointed
down to the 30 and the other half is
gonna be right between the six and the
seven because it's half past six there's
actually a couple ways to solve this but
let's take a look and see how they did
it note a clock is a complete circle
having 360 degrees in one hour the hour
hand covers 360 over 12 so it equals 30
degrees for each hour in one minute the
minute hand covers 360 degrees over 60
minutes or 6 degrees per minute the
minute hand has traveled for 30 minutes
so it has covered 30 times 6 which
equals 180 degrees so we know that's 180
degrees from the 12. the hour hand has
traveled for 6.5 hours 6 and a half 6.5
so it's covered 6.5 times 30 which
equals 195 degrees the difference
between the two will give the angle
between the two hands thus the required
angle equals 195 minus 180 equals 15
degrees and this is nice the way they
solved it because you can now punch in
any kind of time within reason the hard
part is on the hours is you have to be
able to convert the hours into decimals
explain dimensionality reduction and
list its benefits dimension reduction
refers to the process of converting a
set of data having vast dimensions into
data with lesser dimensions fills to
convey similar information concisely it
helps in data compressing and reducing
the storage space it reduces computation
time as less dimensions lead to less
computing it removes redundant features
for example there's no point in storing
a value in two different unit units
meters and inches and i certainly ran
into a lot with this with text analysis
i've been known to run a text analysis
over a series of documents ends up with
over 1.4 million different features
that's a lot of different words being
used and if you do what they call buy
connect them you connect two words
together now you're up to 4.8 million
different features and you start having
to figure ways to bring that down what
can we get rid of that kind of thing so
you can see where that can get really
high in on processing and learning how
to reduce the list dimensions is very
important how will you calculate
eigenvalues and eigenvectors of a three
by three matrix
and what they're really looking for here
is when you write it out for the eigen
is that you know that you're going to
use the lambda that's the most common
one obviously you can use any symbol you
want but lambda is usually what they use
and that you do it down the middle
diagonal and so when you take that
matrix and you take the characteristic
equation you end up with the determinant
and that's the minus two minus lambda
minus four two minus two one minus
lambda two four two five minus lambda
and that's what they're looking for and
you know that's equal to zero so when
you're doing a matrix in the eigen setup
with the eigenvectors that's all going
to come out equal to zero and then you
can go ahead and write the whole
equation out so we can expand the
indeterminant as you can see right here
the minus 2 minus lambda times it's a
mouthful i'll leave it up here for a
second so you can look at it when you
break it down into the algebraic
functions you end up with minus lambda
cubed plus 4 lambda squared plus 27
lambda minus 90 equals zero so now we
have a nice algebraic equation built
from the eigenvectors and always
remember you can hit the pause button
and you can also send a note send a note
to simplylearn if you have more
questions on vectors or on this
definitely have that resource available
to you
or post down in below on the youtube
video comments and so when we calculate
the eigenvalues and eigenvectors of a
3x3 matrix as we continue on down the
math of this and to be honest i really
don't like working with matrixes like
this it's important to understand the
math behind it and it's important to
know the code just enough so that you're
not lost when someone's explaining it or
it comes up when i'm working on
different data science models of course
if you're dealing with the high end math
side of it then you better know this
first is by hitting trial so you try in
different variables to solve for zero
and you can come in here and you'll find
that if we put in the three in there we
end up with a zero at the end and
substitute the three hence we end up
with lambda minus three is one of the
factors and you can do the math going
out on that where we have lambda cubed
minus four lambda squared minus 27
lambda plus 90 equals lambda minus 3
times lambda squared minus lambda minus
30. so eigenvalues based on that one are
three minus five and six and then from
there we can calculate the eigenvector
for lambda equals three and you can see
here where the matrix as we write it out
is the minus five minus four two minus
two minus two minus two four two two
that's from the beginning put in the x y
and z equals zero zero zero and so when
we put in those numbers and we calculate
them out we have for x equals one we
have the minus five minus four y plus
two z equals zero minus two minus two y
plus two z equals zero and subtracting
the two equations we just had we get
three plus two y equals zero y equals
minus three over two and z equals a
minus one over two that's going back to
the first equation and similarly we can
calculate the eigenvectors for minus
five and six
how should you maintain your deployed
model distribution time my favorite i
spent ten years in software distribution
so first thing and this is true not just
of your data science model but of any
computer code going out there this basic
setup can work although usually there's
a little added steps in there first
we're going to monitor it so we have a
constant monitoring of all the model is
needed to determine the performance
accuracy of the models so yeah we want
to just keep an eye on it we want to
make sure they're accurate we want to
make sure that whatever they're supposed
to predict or i threw in that bonus word
post script where you change something
and you want to figure out how your
changes are going to affect things we
need to monitor it and make sure it's
doing what it's supposed to do
evaluation metrics of the current model
is calculated to determine if new
algorithm is needed and then we compare
it the new models are compared against
each other to determine which model
performs the best and then we do a
rebuild the best performing model is
rebuilt on the current state of data
this is interesting i found this out
just recently if you're in weather
prediction the really big weather areas
have about seven or eight different
models depending on what's going on and
so you actually have almost a little
force going on there where they're like
which model is going to fit best and
this is what we're going to use to
predict the weather with so not only do
you don't necessarily get rid of the
models but you figure out which models
fit data of what's going on or the
current state of data what are
recommender systems most commonly used
nowadays in marketing so very big
industry understanding recommender
systems predicts the rating or
preference a user would give to a
product and they they're split into two
different areas one is collaborative
filtering and a good example of that is
the last.fm recommends tracks that are
often played by other users with similar
interests so people who if you're on
amazon people who bought this also
bought that this got me a few times and
then there's contact based filtering and
we're looking at content instead of
looking at who else is listening to the
music leave the example pandora which
uses the properties of a song to
recommend music with similar properties
so you have collaborative filtering and
content based filtering how to find rmse
and msc in linear regression model
hopefully you remember what the two
acronyms mean because that is like half
the answer we have the root mean square
error and the mean square error in
linear regression model so we're looking
for error the rmse and the msc are the
two of the most common measures of
accuracy for a linear regression model
and you can see here we have the root
mean square error rmse equals and this
is the square root of
the sum of the predicted minus the
actual squared over the total number so
we're just looking for the average mean
so we're looking for the average over
the end and the reason you need to know
about the difference between rmse versus
mse is when you're doing a lot of these
models and you're building your own
model why do you need to take the square
root of it it doesn't change the value
as far as the way you're using it
because you're looking as to see whether
the error is greater or less than so why
add that extra computation in so a lot
of models use the msc which indicates
the mean square error or the average
error and it's the same formula minus
the square root at the end or across the
whole thing oh another riddle to solve
if it rains on saturday with a
probability of 0.6 and it rains on
sunday with a probability 0.2 what is
the probability that it rains this
weekend and the trick in probabilities
on this case is we're not we need to
know what is the probability of it not
raining what is it not what's the chance
of it not raining on saturday and if it
doesn't rain on saturday we want to take
that and combine that with the chance of
it not raining on sunday the total
probability which in this case we're
just going to use one minus the
probability that it will not rain on
saturday so it's 1 minus 0.6 we're going
to take that as a union which we simply
just multiply them together of the
probability they will not rain on sunday
and it's important to recognize the
union here or the and you can see by the
formula down here we end up with 0.68 or
68 chance that it will rain on the
weekend and there are a couple other
ways to solve this but this is probably
the most traditional way of doing that
how can you select k for k means
so first you better understand that what
k means is and that k is the number of
different groupings and most commonly we
use is the elbow method to select k for
k means the idea of the elbow method is
to run k-means clustering on the data
set where k is the number of clusters
within the sum of squares wss is defined
as the sum of the squared distance
between each member of the cluster and
its centroid and you should know all the
terms for your k means on there and with
the elbow point and again here's our
iteration in our code we talked about
that earlier you iterate starting with
um usually you don't start right at one
but you might start with two three or
four and you just see where it comes out
and you can see the nice elbow there
which is easy to see graphically where
the number of k clusters and the wss
value drops and then it just kind of
flattens out and there's no reason to
take the k means any further what is the
significance of p value oh good one
especially if you're dealing with r
because that's the first thing that pops
up p-value typically less than or equal
to 0.05
indicates a strong evidence against the
null hypothesis and you should know what
a difference why we use null hypothesis
instead of the hypothesis so you reject
the null hypothesis very important that
term null hypothesis in any scientific
setup and also in data science it
doesn't mean that it's true it means
that there's a high correlation that
it's true so if your null hypothesis
means it's not true your hypothesis is
has a high correlation that it's
probably true and if the p-value is
typically greater than .05 it indicates
a weak evidence against the null
hypothesis so you fail to reject the
whole null hypothesis and if you reject
that then your actual hypothesis is
probably not true the correlation of
your data with what you think it's
saying is is probably incorrect and if
you're right at the cutoff of 0.05 it's
considered to be marginal could go
either way and again you can use that p
value on different features to decide
whether you're going to include your
features as far as something worth
exploring in your data science model how
can outlier values be treated oh good
one you can drop outliers only if it is
a garbage value so sometimes you end up
with like one outlier that just is
probably someone's measurements way off
height of an adult equals abc feet this
cannot be true as height cannot be a
string value in this case outliers can
be removed if the outliers have extreme
values they can be removed for example
if all the data points are clustered
between 0 to 10 but one point lies at
100 then we can remove this point and
again sometimes you just look for the
outliers so you can see what's going on
if there's something unusual there so
maybe the equipment's not calibrated
correctly if you cannot drop outliers
you can try the following try a
different model data detected as
outliers by linear model can be fit by
nonlinear model so we be sure you are
choosing the right model so if it has
like more of a curved look to it instead
of a straight line you might need to use
something other than just a straight
line linear model try normalizing the
data this way the extreme data points
are pulled to a similar range if you can
use algorithms which are less affected
by outliers example random forest so
there is another solution is you can
come up with the random force which a
lot of times completely bypasses your
outliers how can you say that a time
series data is stationary oh that's an
interesting term stationary meaning it's
not moving but it's a time series we can
say that a time series is stationary
when the variance and mean of the series
is constant with time and this graphic
example is very easy to see we have our
the variance is constant with time so we
have our first variable y and x and x
being the time factor and y being the
variable as you can see goes through the
same values all the time it's not
changing in the long period of time so
that's stationary and then you can see
in the second example the waves get
bigger and bigger so that's
non-stationary here the variance is
changing with time again we have y which
stays constant so that if you look at
the bigger picture it's the same wave
over and over again and then of course
we have where the wave is growing in
size going up it can also go down so
it'd also be non-stationary how can you
calculate accuracy using confusion
matrix oh great one confusion matrixes
are so useful when you're taking that
first look at data and also when you're
showing the shareholders and you want to
ask them for money how can you calculate
accuracy using confusion matrix so you
have your total data that we're looking
at is 650 and you have your predicted
values and your actual values and your
predicted p and your actual p and so we
look at this you'll note that if the
predicted p and the actual p are 262 but
our predicted p also had 15 that weren't
correct so you can see there's a false
positive there of 15 and the same thing
with the n you can see where n predicts
n and it has a false negative of 26 out
of the total number of n values in there
and so we can do an accuracy on there
the true positive plus the true negative
is our total observations so you have a
total of 0.93 accuracy or 93 percent and
just a quick note on this this is so
important because it's one thing if
someone is being diagnosed with say
cancer you know this is life death or is
my nuclear reactor going to blow up
suddenly if the p is the probability of
it blowing up and this let's say you
have 15 that's a lot less than say the
26 chances of it blowing up you know so
the actual domain of your data is very
important so if you're non-positive you
don't really care about the predicted
value having non-positive as positive
because they're going to do a biopsy on
the cancer or whatever anyway but you're
very interested if you have a positive
an actual positive value which is looked
at as negative a false negative that's
really important in that domain
depending on what domain you're in write
the equation and calculate precision and
recall rate and so continuing with our
confusion matrix i was just talking
about the different domains we have the
precision equals 262 over 277 so your
precision is the true positive over the
true positive plus false positive and
the recall rate is your true positive
over the total positive plus false
negative and you can see here we have
that 262 over 277 equals a 94
and the recall over here is the 262 over
280 which equals 9.9 or 90
and oh good we're going to take a pause
for another brain teaser if a drawer
contains 12 red socks
16 blue socks and 20 white socks how
many must pull out to be sure of having
a matching pair the last time i went
through these kind of brain teaser
things was like 20 years ago and i had
six people sitting across the table
waiting for my answer that's kind of
mind-numbing when you're in an interview
like that hopefully you're not stuck in
an interview like that but uh on this
you need to ask yourself how many
different colors of socks are there so
they've thrown a lot of extra data in
here that you don't need to solve the
answer the answer is four an example
your first pick is white your second
pick is red third pick is blue so no
pairs yet and that means when you get to
the fourth pick there's a hundred
percent chance you're going to have a
match so the most is going to be four
that you ever have to pull out of your
drawer if it was four colors the answer
would be five and so on it doesn't
matter how many white socks you have or
how many red socks or blue socks
different pairs you have it's the
different colors a number of different
colors people who bought this also
bought recommendations seen on amazon as
a result of which algorithm
we covered this earlier recommendation
engine is done with collaborative
filtering collaborative filtering
exploits the behavior of other users in
their purchase history in terms of
ratings selection etc it makes
predictions on what you might interest a
person based on the preference of many
other users and this algorithm features
of the items are not known and we have a
nice example here where they took a
snapshot of a sales page it says for
example suppose x number people buy a
new phone and then also buy tempered
glass with it next time when a person
buys a phone he'll be recommended to buy
tempered glass along with it and if you
remember the
vocabulary words we covered earlier this
is the recommendation this is
collaborative the other word was content
based so looking at things with similar
content versus collaborative which is
similar people remember you know you're
not going to know every vocabulary word
but it also doesn't hurt to get your
three by five cards out and make
yourself a vocabulary stack of cards
buy an app on your phone for it sql
query i remember back in the 90s it was
so important to know sql query and only
a few people got it nowadays it's just
part of your kit you have to know some
basic sql so write a basic sql query to
list all orders with customer
information and you can kind of make up
your own name for the database and you
can pause it here if you want to write
that down on a paper and let's go ahead
and look at this we have to list all
orders with customer information and so
usually you have an order table and a
customer table and you have an order id
a customer id order number total amount
and then from your customer table you
have id first name last name city county
and so if we're going to write in sql
with this we're going to select keyword
there for sql selecting order number
total amount first name last name city
country so that's the columns we're
going to look at we're going to do that
from our order where we're going to join
it with our customer and we're going to
join it on the order customer id equals
the customer id so very basic sql query
that's going to return a table of data
for us you are given a data set on
cancer detection you've built a
classification model and achieved an
accuracy of 96 percent whoo 96
why shouldn't you be happy with your
model performance what can you do about
it that's an interesting one because
this comes up that's one of the standard
data sets on there is for cancer
detection cancer detection results in
imbalanced data in an imbalanced data
set accuracy should not be based as a
measure of performance because it is
important to focus on the remaining four
percent which are the people who were
wrongly diagnosed we talked a bit about
this earlier you have to know your
domain you know this is the medical
cancer domain versus weather domain you
know whether channel they get by with 50
wrong in cancer you don't want four
percent of the people being wrongly
diagnosed wrong diagnosis is of a major
concern because there can be people who
have cancer but we're not predicted so
in an imbalanced data set accuracy
should not be used as a measurement
performance which of the following
machine learning algorithm can be used
for inputting missing values of both
categorical and continuous variables so
we have a couple choices here we have k
means clustering we have linear
regression we have the k in in nearest
neighbor and decision tree and which of
the following machine learning
algorithms can be used for inputting
missing values of both categorical and
continuous variables now certainly you
can use some preprocessing to do some of
that but you should have gone with the k
nearest neighbor because it can compute
the nearest neighbor and if it doesn't
have the value it just computes the
nearest neighbor based on all the other
features where when you're dealing with
k-means clustering or linear regression
you need to do that in your
pre-processing otherwise it'll crash
decision trees also although there's
some variants on that too can you solve
another riddle always fun ones given a
box of matches and two ropes not
necessarily identical measure a period
of 45 minutes and in this particular
setup the ropes are not uniform in
nature and the rope takes exactly 60
minutes to completely burn out so each
rope takes up to 60 minutes to burn out
and there's actually a couple different
solutions to this but let me go ahead
and one of the things is they're not
uniform in nature so even though they
take 60 minutes anyways let's go ahead
and see what they did to solve it and
then we can also look at different
options we have two ropes a and b light
a from both ends and b from one end okay
when a is finished burning we know that
30 minutes have elapsed and b has 30
minutes remaining now like the other end
of b
also so that the remaining part of b
will burn taking 15 minutes to burn this
we have gotten 30 plus 15 equals 45
minutes excellent solution mine which i
like
was to take one rope fold it in two so
we know it's a half hour take the other
rope fold it in four places so we know
that that one's 15 minutes and then you
can just connect the two and burn it
straight across i think they're trying
to cover that by saying they're not
regular the ropes are have some
irregularities maybe that's what they
meant by that you couldn't do something
like that that's my solution below are
the eight actual values of target
variable in the train file so we have a
training file not to be confused with
the train on the tracks we have zero
zero zero one one one one one what is
the entropy of the target variable we
mentioned earlier that you should know
your entropy and how to calculate the
entropy what is the entropy of the
target variable so we have a couple
options here we have minus five over
eight logarithm of five over eight plus
three over eight logarithm of three over
eight okay let's just see where they got
those numbers from we have uh one which
is going to be five ones and three zeros
and then we have a total of eight okay
and then we have the option of five
which is number of ones five eight
logarithm of five eighths plus three
eighths logarithm of three eighths and
we also have three eighths logarithm of
five eighths plus five eight logarithm
of three eighths and then we kind of
reverse those numbers around and let's
see what you're going to get here which
one did you think it was you should
check the first one so what is the
entropy of the target variable the key
there is a target variable so we're
looking at the target in this case is
going to be one usually that's what
you're looking for and so the entropy of
that one we want to subtract out the
entropy of the non-targeted variable
whoops i had that backwards we want to
we're looking at zero so we want to
subtract out the 5 8 from there so 5 8
logarithm 5 8 or negative 5 8 logarithm
5 8 plus 3 8 logarithm 3 8. and they
have the hint on the bottom entropy
equals i of p of n so we have a negative
p plus p n times the logarithm base 2 of
p over p plus n minus the n over p plus
n times logarithm 2 of n over p plus n
we want to predict the probability of
death from heart disease based on three
risk factors
age gender and blood cholesterol level
what is the most appropriate algorithm
for this case so we have three features
and we want to know the predictability
of death okay a little morbid there
choose a right algorithm do we want to
use logistic regression for this
linear regression k means clustering or
the aproria algorithm and if you
selected logistic regression then you've
probably got the right answer linear
regression remember deals with like you
take your line and draw a line through
the data of course you don't necessarily
have to use a straight line there's
other means for that but you're dealing
with a lot of numbers and k-means means
we're just going to cluster objects
together with the logistic regression
though you can mix those things together
in buckets so really the logistic
regression is what you want to use in
that model would be the most apt fit
after studying the behavior of a
population you have identified four
specific individual types who are
valuable to your study you would like to
find all users who are most similar to
each individual type which algorithm is
most appropriate for this study
certainly identifying census and just
about a lot of different markets is
common so maybe they have a census or
whatever it means but let's take a look
at some of the different algorithms we
might use on this we have k-means
clustering linear regression association
rules and decision trees and i'll give
you a hint we're looking for
grouping people together by similarities
and by four different similarities so
very specific they gave you one of the
values specifically the k value so k
means clustering would be great for this
particular problem you have run the
association rules algorithm on your data
set and the two rules banana apple is
associated with grape and apple orange
is associated with grape have been found
to be relevant what else must be true so
this would change you to understand
association rules you could picture in
this particular one you're going
shopping and uh you almost always see
somebody who has bananas they usually
have grapes in their bag also and
somebody who has apples usually has
grapes in their bags and then apples and
oranges is also associated with grapes
and let's go and take a look at that and
we have a couple different options here
first one is banana apple and grape
orange must be a frequent item set not
so much banana apples oranges must be
relevant rule grape is common with
banana apple must be a relevant rule and
how about grape apple must be a frequent
item set let's go back and take a look
at that and we notice that we have
bananas apples to grapes we have apple
orange to grape boy there's a lot of
grapes and a lot of apples in there and
so if you said the last one grape and
apple must be a frequent item set then
you got it correct your organization has
a website where visitors randomly
receive one of two coupons it is also
possible that visitors to the website
will not receive a coupon you have been
asked to determine if offering a coupon
to visitors to your website has any
impact on their purchase decision which
analysis method should you use and so
let's go ahead and start by giving you
another hint and give you some limiting
your selection we have a one way anova k
means clustering association rules and
student t test so obviously you should
know what each one of these means but
let's take a look at the question again
so you want to know which method should
you use to see if the coupons are valid
for their purchase well we're not
clustering and we're not associating
things together we want to know the end
result student t-test also drawing that
little t in boxes and switch them around
there's really only one answer that
works in here and that's a one-way anova
so that draws us to an end i want to
thank you for joining us today for more
information visit www.simplylearn.com
get certified get ahead feel free to
visit our website and ask any additional
questions you have you can also post
questions down below in the youtube
video and we'll try to get that one of
our experts will try to reach out to you
and answer those questions again thank
you for joining us and happy learning
and since these are interview questions
good luck on your next interview or if
you're the interviewer looking for
questions to ask people good luck on
your next interview
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn youtube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos turn it up and get certified
click here
you